a big trade involving a former mvp and
russell westbrook it's been reported
that
the guy who averaged triple-double in
his fourth time in
five seasons is now a member of the los
angeles lakers the wizards getting
returned kyle kuzma montrez harrell
catavius caldwell pope in the 22nd
overall pick what do you think of
this trade smitty well i love it
russ is getting a chance to go back to
l.a he's playing with lebron and anthony
davis
uh and it's it's crazy to say b shaw
andy and chris that
this guy with that motor takes the
pressure off
lebron for me now in a fast break
situation i thought lebron
we all know he's one of the best but
handling the basketball got a push pace
create tempo at times i just thought
they needed somebody else and dennis
schruter i thought was gonna be that guy
he was okay at it this is one guy right
now is
he's gonna take one or two three people
with him dunk it
pass it even if he misses it that gives
it gives so many offensive
lanes for everybody and i think you know
people don't really understand
his passing and seeing the game has
gotten better sometimes you can just get
assist
but i think right now he knows where he
wants to go now he's settled into being
a veteran
and he wants to win still and he plays
extremely hard i thought this was
fantastic for the lakers
go ahead well you know it was it was two
short years ago um
you know that i was coach on the
coaching staff in la
and and i like russell going back to his
hometown
the question that i have is what style
of play that they're going to play
frank vogel typically his teams have
been
uh towards the bottom of the league in
terms of scoring
uh output in the league in the pace of
play and so
russell westbrook obviously thrives in
the in the
in the fast on the fast break getting
out in the open and putting the pressure
on the defense
and attacking the rim so kyle kuzma who
they're losing in this
was in my estimation one of the best
lane runners
in the league right so you take that
away you take away kentavious caldwell
pope who was one of their best defenders
on the perimeter
a guy who could space the floor and
knock down shots
where's the shooting going to come from
you know they lost danny green a couple
years ago or after the championship
season
and that hurt them so if you got russell
pushing the ball
i don't see lebron at this stage really
getting up and down the floor with him
or anthony davis for that matter so what
style of play
that they play is going to be
interesting here's my question though
for the two of you
among the big three now that they have
uh correct me if i'm wrong
he is arguably the one that would be the
healthiest
and you know clearly we've seen with a.d
and lebron
they've been banged up and they've been
they have missed a lot of games and at
least
with russell westbrook you can at least
feel like you're
you're more likely to have one of your
mvps
out there on a consistent basis because
it might be hard to project that you're
always going to get
all three or certainly a.d and lebron
yeah is that a fair point it's a fair
point andy i mean obviously you know
lebron's
you can't play forever i mean i i take
my hat off to him and anthony davis
you know he's been just a lot a lot of
knack and injuries and i think russell
westbrook
he's going to he's going to play through
his injuries but i think to be shaw's
point is
is what they put around them is going to
obviously help those guys
those guys right now is going to have to
find and make and develop other guys for
them to be great
but uh russell is gonna be exciting uh
it's gonna be interesting to see who
gets it off the glass
i can see right now bishop lebron asking
for it
russell asking for it uh it's gonna be
good to watch i'm looking forward to
this
interesting comment you made you said oh
one of those other mvps lebron's career
this will be the third
former mvp he's played with uh shaq in
2010 which was
definitely the tail end of his career
and then derrick rose played 16 games
with lebron in 2017-2018 so
as many great players as lebron has
played with a former mvp
this will be the first time a guy is in
the middle of his career
russell westbrook did have this tweet as
well thank you dc
you welcomed me and my family with open
arms from day one everyone from the
front office to the training staff the
coaches my teammates and the fans
i'm grateful you took a chance and
supported me every step of the way
especially that guy chris miles
always